machine à coudre c'est un instrument bon
pour le musée
[Musique]
Jean pas d'autres instruments qui me
permettent d'aller plus vite que le
marteau n'est pas étonnage
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît par là
et de cuir et dans l'oreille sont un
plus des fleurs naturelles elles sont
toutes différentes ce qui fait que sur
la peau on les voit très joli sur la
peau
une robe un peu sage c'est une aussi une
robe avec des plans naturels une robe
longue un peu épices
très aéré c'est comme une côte de maille
comment fait-on ces trous là en
découpant dans le métal des formes qu'on
assemble par les anneaux
et c'est vous qui avez appuyé ce métier
à vos ouvrières et à vos ouvriers c'est
vous apprenne tout seul je crois il
suffit d'être intelligent pour
comprendre tout de suite la façon de
faire que faites-vous avec ceci pour
assembler les différents éléments
métalliques entre eux
dans toutes les usines autour de Paris
qu'est-ce que tu me conseilles
c'est pas mal
encore et je ne sais même pas si je
désire de devenir ça m'intéresse
absolument pas
[Musique]
je suis un technicien venu d'un
enseignement technique l'architecture
un homme passionné de son époque
vraiment vivant dans ce temps-ci et
pleinement dans ce temps
amoureux absolu de ce temps et voulant
l'exprimer par son métier parce qu'il
fait certaines de mes vêtements certains
de vêtements essaient de
refléter en vêtements les mêmes
préoccupations qu'un parc en peinture je
le parc fait des sculptures l'aquitté la
toile il fait des peintures avec des
morceaux de métal je fais aussi des
robes avec des morceaux de métal
[Applaudissements]
je ne fais pas de vêtements de saison ça
m'intéresse absolument pas je ne fais
pas d'événements de pour la journée ça
m'intéresse pas ça m'intéresse pas non
plus je crois que les autres créateurs
de vêtements font des vêtements pour
tous les jours très bien j'essaie de
faire des vêtements de circonstances
d'événements qui ont servi à certaines
femmes à se composer une attitude à ce
qu'on faisait un personnage pour dans
certaines
occasions bien particulières je trouve
que vraiment les couturiers ont peu
d'estime de même se prennent pour des
dieux et en même temps s'insulte
eux-mêmes puisque ils n'ont pas le
courage
de regarder le temps présent et de
l'exprimer sera faire toujours un passé
mort et alors les modes en 1925 son 1920
1900 et maintenant on parle de 1930
c'est absolument insensé personne n'ose
parler de 1968 pour moi beaucoup de mes
contemporains
ils ne parlent que du passé des poètes
passé des romanciers morts des musiciens
morts ils écoutent la musique mortes ils
sont dans des meubles morts dans des
immeubles morts c'est vraiment des
cadavres ils n'ont rien à faire avec
l'époque contemporaine
quand je fais quelque chose j'aime bien
que ça sache que je l'ai fait c'est pour
voir si le geste que j'ai fait est
inutile ou pas pour voir si il a une
répercussion
c'est pas une ambition c'est une
curiosité énorme
je trouve c'est très important d'être
curieux on fait quelque chose et puis on
attend de voir la réaction renouvelez
totalement différent
que les gens aiment ce qu'on fait on
n'aime pas vraiment ça ça m'est
totalement égal mais j'aime bien de voir
si la réaction si les gens particuliers
je trouve ça formidable s'il reste ils
applaudissent sur sa formidable pour le
moment ces vêtements sont un peu trop
spectaculaires donc ce sont les gens du
spectacle qui ont commencé à les acheter
la jante cinéma les gens de théâtre et
certaines femmes du monde je n'oubliais
pas quand même que le Tout-Paris c'est
un spectacle continuellement ils ont
donc au besoin de ces armes de parade
que ressent ce genre de vêtements
chaque vêtement de refléter quelque
chose
je cherche à faire d'un vêtement qui va
rendre la femme bizarre un autre qui va
faire une femme très sophistiquée un
autre qui va la rendre moderne à notre
agressif à notre érotique à notre
j'avais vraiment comment était un tout
jeune
ça met la femme en valeur ça leur fait
briller davantage ça la met en confiance
c'est le rôle d'un vêtements c'est de
charmer c'est de provoquer l'amour chez
les autres l'amour qui est quand même le
ressort de toute activité on dit que
vous vendez du vent que vous vendez des
trous que vous vendez des vêtements qui
ne servent à rien qui ne protège ni
contre le foie ni contre la chaleur et
pourtant les femmes les achètent je
crois que tous les couturiers vendent du
vent la mode est aussi du vent on va au
fond la femme des belles connues
c'est de la ferraille c'est de la
ferraille il y a des trous
il est en ferraille où il est en tissu
c'est exactement le même propos
pourquoi nous faites-vous pas des robes
en bois
mais le support de l'égalité colonne est
passé solide et soit j'abandonne cette
idée mais dans le futur si je trouve un
support plus solide je ferai de bois
c'est très beau de voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
absolument pas je suis très lucide très
logique très raisonnable font je crois
d'être un des plus
classiques et les plus raisonnables
créateurs de vêtements qu'il y a
actuellement à Paris
nous ici on s'amuse terriblement
parfois on fait des vêtements on essaie
sur un mannequin et on meurt de rire on
sait pendant une journée entière c'est
très drôle
dans le fond vous exploitez un petit peu
les gens
je vois que tous les gens qui font la
mode
exploitent un peu
imbécilité des gens
parce que pour être dans le coup pour
être dans le vent pour être à la mode
à toute une bande de gogo on fait avaler
n'importe quoi
il y en a beaucoup oui j'exploite des
gens
des gens qui me demandent qu'à exploiter
ils sont stupides que c'est facile pour
eux mais ce n'est pas
il n'y a pas que heureusement les autres
saute qui essaient de qui aiment qui
comprennent un peu plus
et qui eux ne sont pas les imbéciles
[Musique]